ya le calendrier et les chroniqueurs ont
voulu faire un cadeau à cheveux ils ont
refait ton talent dit alors on va revoir
les photos de clara d'aller voir et vous
allez voir c'est le cadeau des
chroniqueurs à clara ca devrait très
plaisir
bach garde donc là ça c'est toi ça c'est
ça c'est le sait la page 2 après on peut
voir s'il vous plaît en régie merci pour
les téléspectateurs merci on à janvier
alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est un mec pas voilà donc on peut en
voir mokhtar c'est un mois dans deux
mois y'a tout à voir mais pourquoi vous
n'avez pas mis les avants après les
chaînes on voudrait les deux photos ya
quelqu'un qui produit ce thème histoire
oui mais ça marche bien sur un sacrifice
au sérieux aussi jean alemany cité
projet de la mine pedro chromé à we are
et qu'en même temps je leur disais qu'on
s'en fout rome et un autre mois là c'est
qui qui à quatre pattes sous toit jsc
m'a alors ah oui pas mal oui merci papa
merci clara ça vous fait plaisir très
plaisir
ah oui c'est oui surtout kelly je vais
surtout embarqué avec moi non mais moi
c'est ma prise de brasser formidable là
dessus un embranchement belges adorent
et un total a essayé bas exact françois
vous auriez dû le faire mais qu'à ma
croûte